[Music]
so
[Music]
good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock is the party over for the prime
minister we would ask the government
but the minister is not available this
morning the invitation is still open if
you're watching us at number 10 dining
street morning
but we will be talking to labour's
deputy leader angela rainer plus the
conservative mp tobias elwood plus the
former attorney general dominic reeve
plus the smp leader ian blackford and
one labour mp who has lost multiple
family members to covet it's wednesday
the 12th of january
calls to quit the prime minister under
pressure from his own mps over party
gate as he prepares to face questions in
pmqs
the prime minister faces mps for the
first time since a leaked email about a
bring your own booze downing street
gathering i'll bring you the very latest
unforced error novak djokovic blames his
agent for a mistake in his australian
travel declaration as his mother speaks
out
he is tennis player he's not politician
he is not
criminal he is not murder he is just
tennis player the best in the world just
let him play
u-turn the government puts the brakes on
the smart motorway roll out after safety
concerns
gathering dust the millions of lateral
flow tests piled up in a warehouse
despite being ready to go i'll tell you
why
the gp who has who is i should say
prepared to lose her job rather than get
a covert vaccine we'll speak to her at
half past seven about her personal plea
that she's made to the p.m
[Music]
[Applause]
culture takes a new twist as elvis
costello cancels himself saying he'll
stop performing his biggest hits
oliver's army
of fraud over a dodgy blood test today
we'll take a look at what's actually
being done
in that industry to detect disease
and the woman dressing as different
household objects throughout january
this morning asking is the party over
for the prime minister following the
latest allegations boris johnson will
face mps in the house of commons at
pmq's with mps calling for him to resign
over so-called partygate including from
his own political party he's expected to
be asked whether he attended a bring
your own booze drinks party in the
downing street garden during lockdown
the prime minister has repeatedly denied
he is a rule breaker let's take a look
at some of the things that he has said
here we go
on the 1st of december boris johnson
told mps that all guidance was followed
completely
the next day we asked he replied the
guidance is there and i am very keen
that people understand
this on the seventh he told the bbc that
all guidelines were observed
the following day after the video of
allegra stratton boris johnson told mps
i have been repeatedly assured that
rules were not broken
that evening at a downing street
briefing he said all the evidence i can
see people in this building stayed
within the rules
on the 13th of december the prime
minister said i can tell you once again
that i certainly broke no rules
on the 20th after the guardian revealed
that photo of the dining street garden
boris johnson said
those were people at work talking about
work i have said what i have to say
about that
who's kate mccann
downing street the iconic home of
british political power today at the
heart of a row that threatens the man
who currently occupies it
after a day of silence now the reckoning
as boris johnson attends prime
minister's questions his party in
mutinous mood if he has breached his own
guidance if he has it not been truthful
then that is an extremely important
issue and i've said previously if the
prime minister has misled parliament
then he must resign
caroline knox a former government
minister said she was very very sorry
for the row adding in a letter to her
constituents i have no words that can
adequately express how angry i am at the
don't do as i do do as i say attitude
that appears to have prevailed in
downing street
i will not try to explain or excuse but
i will certainly apologize to you for
the conduct that has come to light
today the prime minister will be forced
to say whether he attended that party or
not his answer will define his career
from this point and it'll have
repercussions he won't be able to
control
mps are frustrated angry upset
can he win them and the country around
kate mccann sky news
joined now by peter cardwell a former
special adviser to theresa may and boris
johnson hello to mr cardwell thanks for
joining us on the programme this morning
um
what will be happening at downing street
this morning
panic uh worry
and a desperate attempt to try to get
this over with uh prime minister's
questions today kirsten only needs to
ask the same question six times prime
minister did you attend the party on the
20th of may 2020 yes or no that's all he
needs to ask and boris johnson must give
an answer because the senior civil
servant sue gray he's looking into this
this inquiry the line so far has been to
hide behind that to say to wait for the
inquiry but everybody the newspapers are
not just the national newspapers
regional newspapers as well people up
and down the country people who made
sacrifices during covet asking that
simple question did you attend the party
or not did you break the rules or not
prime minister and he has to have an
answer for that at 12 o'clock today
what could his defense be
i'm not sure there is a defense if he
says yes then it would appear that he
broke the rules and that he lied if he
says no well there are lots of
eyewitnesses he says uh so who say he
was there so i mean boris johnson is
someone who has made a career of getting
out of sticky situations whether he can
get out of this one or not i think
remains to be seen and i think a lot of
people look at those back benches
yesterday behind michael ellis the penny
master general who was sent out on a
real hospital pass to defend the prime
minister it'll be fascinating to see how
many conservative mps are behind the
prime minister today with figuratively
are literally on those green benches and
i'm not sure there'll be that many to be
honest
if you were working for him how would
you start to defend him
i would say that you've got to get
everything in the public domain as soon
as possible i think they've waited too
long i think he should have come out
yesterday about a very tough interview
with a very tough interviewer like uk
and said uh everything about the party
made a full and object apology for what
he did uh to
say that he would
cooperate with any inquiry whether
that's a police inquiry or a civil
service inquiry or whatever inquiry to
get all the details and the public to be
in i think that's all you can do this is
just going to rumble on this is not
going to go away boris johnson cannot
dodge this one he's got to give answers
whether it'll be a prime minister's
questions today whether it'll be in the
inquiry but even with the inquiry i
think people are asking why can you
answer a simple straightforward question
to the senior civil servant to sue grey
but he can't just level with the country
so i think with any scandal like this um
the thing is that okay it's an easy one
to understand things like green sill for
example david cameron scandal that was a
bit complicated who was who who said
what's up to who this is really really
straightforward everybody made
sacrifices i know i had an elderly aunt
uh there were 14 of us at our funeral
many many people up and down the country
watching your program this morning will
have very very similar uh sacrifices
they've made and this is very easy to
understand a lot of anger there and when
you have so many conservative mps you're
not backing the prime minister where is
cabinet colleagues where's the minister
on the morning round of e of interviews
this morning they're not sending people
out to defend this but the prime has
questions to answer he must answer them
i'll answer them quickly if he has any
chance of surviving
rather than coming clean i mean we're
being told this morning that downing
street staff are being told to wipe
information relating to the events of
any parties at dining street during
lockdown from their phones and other
devices um
if they do that does that not mean that
they are complicit
well it would and they absolutely should
not be doing that i know from downing
street staff that i've been speaking to
friends of mine that they are as
outraged as the country there are
certainly some people who attended this
party but the ones i've been speaking to
certainly weren't at the party there's
just anger there's frustration there's a
real desire that this is in some way
dealt with if anybody's deleting any
information that is uh very unethical
and possibly criminal and they
absolutely shouldn't be doing that
um the prime minister has you know he's
teflon isn't he um
things like this have happened to him
before perhaps not to this degree and he
just seems to be able to be a bit boris
like about it and shrug it off um will
he be able to do it this time or is the
game over
you can never underestimate boris
johnson i remember when i was in
government for three and a half years
he'd resigned as foreign secretary he
was holed up in his
portcullis house office in parliament
with one or two aides and everybody
thought you know it's over for boris
he's a busted flush then he remember he
emerges triumphant as prime minister he
is the comeback kid he was sacked twice
once in politics once in journalism and
he came back from that and is now the
most powerful person in the country so
never underestimate boris johnson but at
the same time it's difficult to see how
anybody any politician would get out of
this one but i think the vultures are
circling but there's no clear uh there's
nobody sticking the knife in really just
yet there of course keir starmer has
accused him of lying sired davey this
morning is saying he should resign but
in his own party i don't think there are
those people who say that he is a
liability just yet although the polling
would certainly indicate that that
appears to be the case and i think once
you get
many people on his own party saying that
he's a liability i'm calling for him to
go perhaps ladders going after graham
brady the chairman of the 1922 committee
that's the real danger point but we're
not there just yet
okay it's good to talk to you thanks so
much indeed prime minister's questions
of course at midday today the prime
minister will be turning up for that i
am sure before that although we've got
no minister we've got aleister campbell
uh coming up i'm sure he'll have quite a
few things to say angela rainer as well
for uh labour will she be facing the
prime minister today or will her leader
be back at work again having contracted
covet for the second time tobias elwood
uh the chairman of the defense committee
he will also be with us uh this morning
as well and just looking through my nose
well i don't want to spoil it for you
but we've got one or two other
conservatives as well including hugh
merriman chair of the transport select
committee our political correspondent
tomorrow cohen uh not with me here in
the studio this morning rather at
downing street hello to you tomorrow um
busted flush or the comeback head
hi kay well i think for uh the first
time the real question many tory mps are
asking is how on earth does boris
johnson wriggle out of this one we heard
nothing from him yesterday the first we
will hear from him is today at prime
minister's questions i understand there
won't be any kind of formal statement
before that but he may say a few words
before kierstarma gets stuck in with
those questions which are all going to
be did he attend the party and what did
he know of the organizing of that party
and tory mps are really going to be
hanging on what that explanation is and
if it includes a full and groveling
apology for what many of them think has
been a deep and damaging episode and
it's not just tory mps they know the
public are starting to tire of this too
we did a yougov poll for sky news
yesterday and this is what it showed do
you think boris johnson should resign
from his role as prime minister 56
of those questions said he should 27
said he should remain in the role and 17
said don't know so the jury's very much
out with we've already had a couple of
tory mps saying that this is a resigning
issue and others are waiting to see how
the public reaction pans out over the
next few weeks and especially what the
findings of that civil service inquiry
are as to whether he broke the guidance
or misled mps when he said it had been
followed yes it's survivable in the view
of some ministers but a lot will hang on
what boris johnson says today
okay tomorrow thanks tomorrow's take of
course at nine o'clock this morning what
do you think that was the yougov poll
that we carried out on your behalf
yesterday do you think that the prime
minister should step down given what we
have been hearing of events in may of
2020 when the streets were empty in your
town because we were under severe
lockdown have you got a thought on that
benedict and fergus are standing by if
you would like to tweet me and let me
know your thoughts at cape early we'll
share that with the rest of the world
throughout the course of the programme
today as i said no minister today edward
argher the health minister put his big
boy pants on yesterday and came to
answer some questions about that party
at downing street um he
along with others that we have spoken to
hid behind sue gray she is the woman
that is carrying out the investigation
into what happened at downing street um
15 times
he talked about sue gray
it's absolutely right that sue grey a
very senior and very well respected
civil servant is independently looking
into these it's why it's right that this
is looked into independently by sue gray
i mean it's right that sue grey is
looking into this matter independently i
have to repeat it because it's the it's
the right thing to do is that that's up
to ms gray to look into it's important
that ms gray as an independent figure um
an independent civil servant looks into
this they're being investigated by sue
grey i'm going to let sue grey get on
with her job not going to pre-judge what
sue wolf sue grey will find happened on
that occasion what actually happened or
didn't happen in downing street is a
matter for ms gray and that's what sue
gray is going to be looking at i'm not
going to prejudge what sue wolf sue grey
will find happened on that occasion i'm
not going to
give a commentary on what ms gray may or
may not conclude
15 times in total that was just a flavor
and the party's fallout is uh dominating
the newspapers this morning starting
with the telegraph reporting that boris
johnson is losing support from within
his own party as the shadow of the
alleged downing street party's haunt
number 10. it's always interesting when
you see a story about boris johnson on
the front of the telegraph they tend to
try to dodge it when they can usually a
supporter of boris johnson you know it's
serious when he's on the front page the
eye says the pm's future is in jeopardy
as conservatives hit out at the
government that's what the eye is saying
this morning the ft johnson faces
potentially terminal showdown over
downing street parties is on the front
of the financial times the guardian says
mps are urging the prime minister to
come clean over whether or not he
attended the party
and the metro suggests the prime
minister has contempt
for the victims
if you've got time to look at page five
of the guardian this morning i actually
ripped it out of the paper so i can
refer to it from time to time today and
they list from the first of december
down to the 20th of december the number
of times the prime minister said he was
not involved with any parties at number
10.
still to come talking to
amongst other people labour's deputy
leader angela rainer about where those
allegations leave the prime minister
later this hour i'll be speaking to the
former director of coms at number 10
under tony blair that was alastair
campbell about the alleged parties at
number 10 during lockdown
also i'm going to be joined by the
conservative mp and chair of the defense
select committee tobias elwood to get
his view on those downing street parties
as well as the tensions on the russian
ukrainian border
and later in the programme i'm going to
be speaking to the smp's westminster
leader that's ian blackwood of course
who's already called for the pm to
resign
ambrose johnson will come under more
scrutiny in the house of commerce of
course this afternoon there will be and
live coverage of prime minister's
questions here on sky news at midday
meantime the tennis star novak djokovic
has apologized for what he calls an
administrative mistake on his travel
declaration his team gave incorrect
information about whether he had
traveled to any third countries before
flying to australia still waiting to
find out he will be allowed to stay in a
statement djokovic said on the issue of
my travel declaration this was submitted
by my support team on my behalf as i
told immigration officials on my arrival
my agent sincerely apologizes for the
administrative mistake in ticking the
incorrect box about my previous travel
before coming to australia this is what
his mom said
i'm very worried so i realized that this
is not over yet and we are all praying
that
that he will stay and he will play so i
hope so that everybody is thinking the
same i hope the ministry the me the the
government and the minister
is thinking uh on the other i mean
don't
let him out don't don't throw him out
he's tennis player he's not politician
he's not
criminal he's not murder he is just
tennis player the best in the world just
let him play
nicole's been in melbourne for us all
week joins us again now aussie open is
due to start on monday of course nicole
good morning good afternoon where you
are um
is it going to be playing or not
well we don't know that's the million
dollar question that we're waiting to
find out from the immigration minister
he's indicated that the delay has taken
place because of this issue over the
travel declaration form that you just
talked about the problem there was novak
djokovic said that in the two weeks
before arriving in australia he hadn't
been in any other country but it turns
out he had been in spain all of these
controversies have forced him to give a
lengthy explanation on instagram the
other issue he had to address were
photos that came out
of him in public settings after he had
had a
covered positive test on the 16th of
december now he has admitted that two
days after that he had a media interview
and a photo shoot
after having a positive covert pcr test
he knew he was positive he said it was
an error of judgment but it's something
that won't play well with the australian
authorities and the public here many
people have been upset to find out that
novak djokovic was entering the country
without being double vaccinated some of
that sentiment has
changed though because people were also
outraged to find out that he had been
put in an immigration detention hotel in
melbourne but right now it's still a
waiting game
the minister involved in this has said
that he's received more submissions and
legal documents from novak djokovic's
team but as for whether he'll appear on
monday
we're still waiting to hear okay nicole
for now thank you
well the government has suspended the
rollout of smart motorways until at
least 2025 because of concerns about
their safer smart motorways were
designed to increase road capacity by
converting the existing hard shoulder to
a live lane but that means there is less
space for broken down vehicles to stop
safely aisha how's this
more than two years ago jason mercer was
killed on his drive to work he'd had a
minor collision with a van on a stretch
of the m1 converted into a smart
motorway moments after the drivers
stopped they were hit by a lorry
mr mercer's wife believes he would still
be alive if the hard shoulder hadn't
been taken away
at first i thought it was
just a tragic accident but the more and
more i learned that it never should have
happened and it didn't need to happen
other people had it happened to them and
campaigners had been shouting about
smart motorways for years and years and
years it just made it so much more
painful
there are three types of smart motorway
all intended to keep traffic moving but
they've sparked safety concerns
following a government inquiry the
rollout has been paused for those where
the hard shoulder is permanently a live
traffic lane where work has been
completed or is underway a retrofit
program will see more refuge areas and
stop vehicle detection technology
installed
we think it is right that the government
takes stock looks at the evidence looks
at all the data and collects all the
data before making a decision as to
whether or not it is right to proceed
ultimately it is the permanent removal
of the hard shoulder and insufficient
emergency refuge areas that is the
problem and you know if a driver stops
in the live lane
then potentially they can be at mercy of
drivers behind them not following
some of the information on the gantry
signs themselves with estimates that
dozens like jason have lost their lives
on these roads this pause will
ultimately allow the government to
evaluate just how smart these motorways
really are aisha zahid sky news
latest business figures are out for the
last financial quarter of 2021
sainsbury's has reported stronger than
expected grocery sales in the six weeks
leading to the eighth of january let's
get more on that should we um ender is
standing by for us in west london um
hello to you ender so um since we've
done better than expected
yeah they have kay good morning to you
um it's a big day really for lots of
famous names on the high street they're
all reporting their last quarter results
which of course include christmas
sainsbury's first down the block this
morning so they are on track
for full-year profits before tax of 720
million pounds mixed bag really general
merchandise down 16 year on year for the
last quarter
grocery sales down 1.1
clothing up 38
and the chief exec simon roberts this
morning revealing that they're investing
100 million pounds now in the coming
weeks into bringing everyone up to at
least 10 pounds an hour from march so
we'll have more results throughout the
morning as we get them
okay for now thanks so much indeed
thanks ladies figures there from
sainsbury's doing better than expected
what's your experience i went to the
supermarket yesterday shelves are empty
is that because so many people are off
with omicron or is that because they
can't get the deliveries because there
aren't enough lorry drivers i don't know
let me know your experience at k early
as i said uh fergus and benedict waiting
to hear from you if you'd like to tweet
me directly have a look at what we found
in the papers for you this morning an
incredible escape from disaster
a medical helicopter crashed in
philadelphia in the united states but
the four people on board including a
young child they all survived which is
absolutely amazing
good for them the aircraft managed to
avoid power cables and buildings before
landing near a church outside
philadelphia yesterday reading to that
what you might it was transporting the
infant to a hospital before it crashed
in transit emergency responders say
they're thankful all involved were
unhurt
we're blessed we're blessed as a
community
we're best blessed as a fire service
police department university management
we are totally blessed it's a miracle
it's an absolute miracle here what you
see behind you how this and there's no
debris no wires down no trees how that
pilot was able to get that plane there
and all four of them were able to get
themselves out of the helicopter with
assistance from the police and the fire
department when we responded
for weeks there's been a desperate
shortage of coveted lateral floaters for
people to use at home now sky news has
been given exclusive access to a
warehouse where millions and millions
and millions of tests are just sitting
there waiting for distribution the
problem has been getting official
approval now that's done they should be
arriving in pharmacies uh becky johnson
reports
stacked to the ceiling row upon row of
boxes packed full of lateral flow tests
ready and waiting at this warehouse in
nottinghamshire to be distributed to
pharmacies across the country
each individual box has almost 400 tests
in fact at this warehouse alone there
are tens of millions of tests all packed
up ready to go
it means while the country faced a
shortage of lateral flow kits these were
sitting ready to use
the first rapid tests manufactured in
the uk to be approved for self-use in
homes here but it took derby-based
company shawscreen around six months to
get that approval has that been
frustrating the length of time it's
taken especially in recent weeks when
you've seen the desperate need for
lateral blow fest in the country yeah
well we just focus on making the best
test we can uh you know and um
we're very aware of why regular
regulations are in place for several
weeks they've been loading lorries with
tests found for national distribution
centers but they've only appeared on
pharmacy shelves in the last few days
too late for those who've had to deal
with the national shortage it has been a
very difficult time for for pharmacies
in that for weeks we have been
highlighting that the demand is very
very high for lateral floor tests
however the supply is not matching the
demand and we're still in the same
situation that many pharmacies are
receiving very little
and some promises actually
don't get anything really a spokesperson
for the uk health security agency said
extensive evaluation is carried out on
tests designed for home use to ensure
they're reliable and accurate evaluation
of this data is part of the regulatory
approval process which can take time
they're able to produce around a million
tests a day here and already export them
to over 50 countries
some will question why it took so long
for them to be approved for home use
here becky johnson sky news
nottinghamshire
we're looking at the latest covet data
for you in the uk 120
821 new cases of corona advice reported
in the last 24 hours 379 more deaths the
highest since february of last year
takes the number of those who died
within 28 days of a positive covert test
to 150
609 people
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you now
parents have been warned about a winter
virus that can cause breathing problems
in very young children the british lung
foundation says respiratory
sun
since i think virus could surge next
winter because children have a much
lower immunity following last winter's
covered lockdown
almost 600 former teachers have come
forward to support schools struggling
with staff shortages due to the pandemic
according to the department for
education it says another hundred have
expressed interest
has learned that a sexual predator was
caught only after investigators at the
fbi contacted the uk's national crime
agency despite more than a dozen of his
victims reporting him to british police
last month 26 year old abdul ilahi was
jailed for 32 years after pleading
guilty to 158 offenses including
blackmailing victims to abuse themselves
their siblings
and children
now a song that many of us will
recognize is here to stay no more
[Music]
elvis costello has revealed he will no
longer perform his biggest hit oliver's
army and has also asked radio stations
to stop playing the song written about
the conflict in northern ireland the
lyrics contain a racial slur used to
describe irish catholics he told the
daily telegraph that he has been accused
of something that i didn't intend in
relation to the use of the slur oliver's
army no more now you've been brought to
tears when uh chopping an onion here's
some good news for you apparently
tearless onions are to go on sale in
british supermarkets for the first time
the so-called sonians
are not genetically modified but the
product of decades of cross-breeding
less pungent strains of the staple
vegetable the new variety is being
billed as a game changer for red eyed
chefs what do you do to stop from crying
when you cut onions i put my glasses on
easy huh quick look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
high pressure means the rest of the week
will be mainly settled with an
increasing risk of fog and frost the
south will start frosty today with some
dense fog patches especially for central
england but the north looks milder
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
how about this for a courageous creature
here we go this is
magawa you remember miguel we've focused
on magawa before hiro landmines sweeping
rat
sadly
now died at the age of eight in 2020
became the first rat to be awarded the
uh
pdsa gold medal the animal equivalent of
the george cross which recognizes acts
of heroism by british citizens and
military personnel in his lifetime he
cleared more than
225 000 square meters of land the
equivalent of about 31 football pitches
and discovered 71 landmines in cambodia
mayhem rest in peace
looking at some of the pictures in the
papers for you this morning here we go
this is what caught our eye
sharing a picture from may of 2020
important data that encapsulates so much
of the uproar around the latest downing
street party allegation two people
outdoors and distanced from one another
appearing to be confronted
by a police officer
on a beach
moving on from that particular
story the times shows akia henry and
michael balogun in costume for the
upcoming royal shakespeare company
production of much ado about nothing i
love this picture set in a futuristic
world and debuting stratford-upon-avon
at the beginning of february
and uh here's an early contender for
photo of the year the express report on
a wild cougar
who's been living an urban life on the
west coast of america there she is the
mountain lion known as p22 has been seen
hunting deer in forest lawn and drinking
from lake hollywood to well-known
celebrity hot spots love that picture as
well how long did it take them to get
that perfectly right
and heidi klum loved this picture as
well in the mail
how amazing does she look um far from
mellow yellow
she's 48. she said on instagram that the
peter dundas number is her favorite
frock i'm sure that a lot of people um
agree with her on that one and finally
ladies uh here's richard hammond and
gentleman away from the wheel here he is
facing up to his trauma and getting
inside the car that very nearly killed
him can you believe that was 1616
years ago he crashed while traveling at
an astonishing
319 miles an hour at the time you can
see he looks uh pretty anxious and
traumatized here's the picture of when
it happened you remember they thought if
it hadn't been for the roll bar he would
most certainly have lost his life took
him a long time to recover faced his
demons got back in the car a couple of
days ago
uh coming up joined by the former
director of coms at number 10 under tony
blair that was alastair campbell on what
the downing street party scandal means
for the pm
[Music]
hello again everybody you'll be tuning
in about this time want you to find out
what the minister had to say about the
prime minister's party um
long force coming this morning sadly
don't know why we know that they do
watch in uh downing street so we've got
until 10 o'clock two and a half hours
very happy to chat to whoever it's
always best to come clean isn't it now
boris johnson's going to be appearing
before mps at pmq's today he's expected
to be asked to confirm whether he
attended a drinks party at downing
street during lockdown in may of 2020
the invite was sent out by his pps
private secretary
the government announces a pause in its
role to smart motorways after safety
concerns
and novak djokovic has apologized for
what he calls an admin mistake on his
travel declaration to enter australia as
the tennis star awaits his fate
just to remember of course as well that
uh from midday today it's going to be
prime minister's question time uh and we
will be hearing uh from the prime
minister for the first time since these
latest allegations of events at downing
street came out so we'll find out what
he has to say no minister this morning
but we do have aleister campbell who is
the former director of communications at
number 10 under tony blair now i know
that you're going to say he's got to
step down
first of all though can i ask you what
you would be doing to try to protect his
reputation if you were representing him
today
well i think he's trashed his own
reputation over many many years and uh i
think what we're seeing today is the
inevitable consequence of having elected
somebody like boris johnson as prime
minister in the first place
uh it's not as if the country didn't
have lots of warnings about the sort of
person he was the sort of person he is
and the way that he conducts himself in
public
and private life and
i don't know what i would say to him to
be absolutely frank because i
well one i wouldn't be there
but secondly
i think that i have the sense that
there's now a culture in there that
basically says johnson can thinks he can
do what the hell he wants and that has
now spread to other people as well so i
honestly don't know okay you're asking i
know you've got to you've got to fill
the tower because you've got no tory
ministers on
and i can't pretend that i'm going to
stand in for them
but i honestly don't know what i would
say to him other than as you said
earlier
it is better
to stand there at the dispatch box and
tell the truth but the problem if he
stands up and tells the truth
is that uh which would be you know
pretty rare thing of itself but the
problem with that
is that then he's probably and almost
certainly going to have to admit that he
broke the laws that he brought in
and that he told the entire country we
had to live by and the vast majority of
people did
enormous in so many cases enormous
sacrifice and that is why this has
become such a
toxic sulfurous issue for him
yeah i'm trying to be even-handed though
alistair and i know and my viewers know
that you are very good at advice you um
did it incredibly well for a long time
while you were at number 10. give it a
go what would you say to him to try to
get him off the hook
you know as you you said it fess up be
honest
um
and if it come now that is that is
difficult because the truth is as i say
they we're talking now about breaches of
the law
just talking about
messing about and
uh some of the stuff that politicians
sometimes get up to we talk about a
breach of the law at an incredibly
difficult point
um but i think that it's always best in
these circumstances because the but the
other thing that's happening now
is because within the so i still know a
lot of people inside the civil service i
know people are leaving at the moment
because they can't stand what's going on
but what happens when you have somebody
at the top who is basically saying i can
do what i want i will blame other people
i will throw other people under the bus
that's when people in your profession
then get all the calls and the leaks and
all the rest of it that is going to
continue and continue and continue
until this guy actually stands up and
starts operating by basic public
standards that most of the public expect
him to one of which is you level with
people
so stop lying stop blustering stop
pretending that you haven't done
anything wrong and instead admit it
accept anything that comes your way with
that apologize to the country and then
try to operate in a different way but i
don't think he's capable of doing it i
really don't
we did a yougov poll um on sky yesterday
a snap poll to find out what people um
thought and this is what it looks like
um 27
of people so almost a quarter of more
than a quarter of those that we asked
still felt that he should remain as
prime minister even if he did break the
rules
well it doesn't actually say that it
just says do you think bryce johnson
should resign from his role as prime
minister whether that number would
change if you actually if it was proven
that he had broken lockdown rules i
don't know but listen that is not a good
position to be in you're talking enough
you're so good at what you do alistair
because you immediately extrapolated
something different from what i was just
illustrating
no i actually i think for any prime
minister to have a situation where fewer
than a third of people
uh think you should still be doing the
job you've got to remember kate most of
the time most people just kind of get on
with their lives and politics is
something happening over there
and you give them a poll i'm not a great
fan of instant polls i'll be absolutely
honest about that because they just tend
to reflect a passing mood but the fact
is you know as a country
we've just got to decide whether we
think that the situation that we've had
over the last couple of years is
tolerable and tenable and the other
thing i think that's really important to
draw out of this this isn't just about
boris johnson these conservatives have
now been in path over a decade and if
it's true by the way and it's
interesting you can't get a minister to
come on this morning but if it's true
that yesterday at the cabinet meeting
this is something your colleagues have
been saying that this wasn't even raised
by a single member of the cabinet then
they really are an utterly spineless
craven bunch this is something that is
affecting the good governance of the
country and that is something for the
entire cabinet to address
what do you think about um
what's been happening as far as the met
is concerned we know of course
that um while uh tony blair was prime
minister he was questioned under caution
about something different but
nevertheless they came forward and
wanted to talk to the then prime
minister um should they be talking to
this one
well it's a very interesting comparison
and i do think whether it's the way that
the media have covered this whether it's
the way that the political system and
parliament have covered this if you go
back to that case that you mentioned
relating to tony blair
that was an investigation mounted on the
basis of a single claim by a single snp
mp
and on that basis the police got
involved and as you say they got sending
yates of the yard trampling all over
downey street and all the rest of it we
have a situation in relation to the
breaches of lockdown
regulations or laws where there is
plenty
plenty of evidence that you'd have
thought was worth investigating and at
every step of this way
the meta line has been we don't have
evidence we don't have evidence to
investigate well your job is meant to be
to find evidence when you think that
there may be
um there may be have been breaches of
the law now we heard yesterday the
metropolitan police are in contact with
the cabinet office
i don't know what that means but at the
time
let me tell you there were two things
going on at the time
this party was what was happening
one is the police were arresting and
cautioning people who were gathering in
groups of more than two outside in you
know several hundred i think it was at
the time
and the second thing to say is that the
day after this party boris johnson was
about clapping on the steps of number
10.
i mean the hypocrisy is what gets me in
this as well and yes i do think the
police have got to you cannot have a
situation where people think that the
police is just an arm of government
and you've had the sense with the met
that they've been bending over backwards
to try not to get involved in this if a
crime has been committed in the garden
of downey street or anywhere where else
in danny street and bear in mind this is
a place where it's probably got more
cctv over it than any other building in
the country so don't tell me the police
don't know what's been going on
okay it's good to talk to you thanks i'm
trying not to take it personally every
time you have a pop at the media on
twitter by the way it's good to talk to
you thank you very much indeed thank you
bye-bye
bye
uh angela reyna the deputy leader um of
the labour party with us right shortly
no government minister today
still time uh before that though from
april frontline nhs staff in england
will need to have the kovid jab or will
be moved to another role the move has
sparked worry among hospital bosses who
fear they'll lose stuff when the new
rules come in
let's talk to dr fu fui me quick
part-time gp doesn't want the vaccine
hello to doctor thanks for joining us
why not
hello hi kay um
there are various reasons but i
i i just made the this decision it's not
like hepatitis b vaccine
which is what i was told i mean that
particular vaccine has a proven safety
record and
has um you know it gives immunity for a
long time gives protection for a long
time whereas the kobe vaccine it was new
there was no long-term safety data so
just being cautious i i just wanted to
to wait and also i did get covered
so i thought my immunity was pretty good
anyway but what happened was i am the
reason i wrote to boris was just because
you've had cove it doesn't mean you
won't get it again does that anyone give
it to anybody else
that's true and even if you've had the
vaccination it doesn't mean you won't
get it
get covered either
but the symptoms are likely to be uh not
as bad as what we're told you would
disagree with that
oh is that the end of that
oh i think it might be okay well i'm
pleased to say that uh despite that i
can wander over guys and uh let's bring
in angela rainer who's standing by for
us we weren't expecting that so i need
to move the furniture around a little
bit miss rainey you'll bear with me
there you go
how are you
it's nice to see you thanks for joining
us this morning no minister this morning
what do you think of that
well i think it's shameful that boris
johnson over the last couple of days
hasn't answered the central
questionnaires yes or no was she at a
party at 10 downing street when everyone
else was in lockdown he could have
cleared this up within the last couple
of days i took the question yesterday
the urgent question he still didn't turn
up to parliament his ministers didn't
turn up to parliament by the unlucky one
that got the short straw and he's still
not answered that question so i think
it's not unsurprising that no one would
turn up today to answer to it because
quite frankly to anyone who lost a loved
one who was not able to visit them and
see them in their dying hours it's
pretty despicable to find that they were
partying at number 10.
he will turn up today because his prime
minister's questions of course if he
doesn't then
that's a whole new uh can of worms isn't
it would you be asking the questions i
don't know yeah it depends on test
results this morning um
i think he's having it this morning i've
been on the media round so i'm not sure
he did test negative yesterday so if
you're testing negative this morning
then he should be fine then he can well
you know kissed almost look so i'm not
taking anything i mean he's had covered
what seventy six thousand times
hey he's had a pretty bad run of it yeah
we wish him better and he was negative
uh yesterday so it was so hopefully
he'll be there this afternoon and he's
had a week to think about what he's
going to ask the prime minister what do
you think his first question will be i
think he'll be as frustrated as the
public are regarding what the prime
minister's done nobody wants to be in
this circumstance when we're at time of
crisis you know the country are facing a
cost of living crisis there's other
things that people are rightly concerned
about at the moment but quite rightly
those that are still grieving those that
remember those dark days of having those
restrictions will be pretty cheesed off
and upset that they see the prime
minister has actually attended a party
in downing street when he's clearly
broken the rules on the law that's not
what we expect and that's regardless of
political persuasions even conservatives
will say that it's not what you expect
from the prime minister of this country
that was then
some might say this is now um and the
conservatives have managed to steer us
through
a global pandemic well if you look at
our death rates they have been pretty
uh shocking we've seen that the waste in
terms of public procurement contracts
and so therefore whilst there has been
you know the vaccination program that
the nhs works on and our great
scientists in the uk was a great success
and continues to be a success there are
failings that the government have shown
throughout the pandemic but this is the
number one critical one for me is that
the prime minister the allegation is is
that he's lied and he's broke the rules
and broke the law and that is the most
serious allegation you can put to a
prime minister at a time of crisis we
had a yug of pearl snap poll yesterday
and still 26 percent of people feel that
the prime minister shouldn't resign
that's a reflection on your party as
much as anything
i think you know people are entitled to
their opinions people are concerned at
the moment they just want to see things
improve for their lives and i completely
understand that but many of the public
now i mean it won't come as a shock to
people that i don't think porris johnson
was the right prime minister for this
country but i think the general
population now in the british public
field that they've been lied to deceived
to and are feeling pretty angry and
upset and those that have lost loved
ones and were not able to be there in
those dying hours feel that the prime
minister has really let them down on a
level that they never expected any prime
minister of this country to do yeah you
only have one vote though and the
majority felt that jeremy corbyn was
certainly not the right prime minister
did the party put up the wrong person
against him well you know we in 2019 we
lost the general election and lost it
very badly and we've had to reflect on
that and since i became deputy leader of
the labour party and care became leader
we've been doing a job of making sure
the public can see that we acknowledge
where we were and that we take those
issues forward that's why this week only
yesterday we were in the house of
commons trying to get the government to
relieve the pressures on working
families around the energy crisis that
we face at the moment so really trying
to show the public that we're on their
side and i think that's starting to cut
through and you know we had to
acknowledge that but the actual you know
what people have seen from this prime
minister over the last uh 12 months and
certainly in the last couple of days
where he hasn't even had the decency to
answer a very simple question was you at
a party at your flat during lockdown
when people were told not to or not i
think shows the level of the man really
that he hasn't been able to come forward
and say that he's a very busy man
perhaps it was on his other phone he
wasn't very busy yesterday it's an
urgent question he's a parliamentary
didn't know what he was doing on the
20th of may well i think the general
public will make their assumptions i
mean we all saw his media appearance
where he was actually smirking when he
was asked the question i think the
british that's an unfortunate mannerism
that he has when he's under pressure i
don't necessarily i think you know and
i'm not the first i'm certainly not
defending boris johnson but that's some
that's what he does when he's under
pressure like
he had the opportunity yesterday through
the urgent question through parliament
to come to the house and to tell the
british public whether he was partying
or not when everybody else was what if
you don't remember well he should
remember i mean i think he'd find it
pretty hard not to remember whether he
was at a lockdown party or not i
certainly didn't have any lockdown
parties and didn't attend any it doesn't
take me to look at my diary to see
whether or not i was at one or not on
that day i know for a fact i was i mean
look how busy he is well we all were but
i think we all know whether or not we
broke lockdown rules
as far as he is um concerned if he did
are you more concerned that he went to
the party or are you more concerned that
he misled parliament
i think you know the frustration is not
only is it around the fact that he
shouldn't have been breaking the law and
breaking the rules and he should come to
the house and speak to the british
people as quickly as possible about that
but it's the fact that for time and time
again now he said that nothing happened
no rules were broken and the allegation
essentially now is that he was actually
attending this party during lockdown so
it shows that he's not only broke the
rules but he's lied to the british
public and i think that makes his
position completely untenable so you're
calling for him to resign i think he i
mean it wouldn't be a surprise that i
think he should go but i think more
crucially now his members of parliament
his conservative mps have to ask
themselves the question is why are we
propping up this man who has lied to the
british public and who has broke the
rules and broke the law
the fact is they are though they're
still uh supporting him
well we'll see what happens today we'll
see what boris johnson has to say for
himself but anyone who props up a liar
who breaks the law to me is you know
that's a completely unacceptable
position
so so what are you suggesting might
happen today because we have been
speaking to other colleagues other peers
um earlier today and they were
suggesting that fewer backbenchers might
be behind him today well i don't know i
mean you could pick up the phone
straight away he could speak to you on
your show and you could clear it off
he could clear it up yeah very difficult
absolutely mr johnson and honestly i can
clear the schedule for you if you're
watching this morning i know you do
watching dining street as you heard from
ms rainer there's room on the sofa for
you exactly as well just come along and
talk to us it's best to come clean it is
and and you know it's it's the british
public that he needs to come clean to
you know they're the people that have
sacrificed so much our nhs workers are
key workers who have provided care and
you know they've sacrificed not seen
their loved ones and they're they're all
upset at the moment they want to know
boris johnson did you have a party in
downey street when everybody else was in
lockdown yes or no he asked to answer
that question today and if he admits to
it and comes clean and says he's sorry
and he apologizes don't we just move on
then i don't think we can on this to be
honest and i think the last couple of
days have shown that the fact that he's
been lying about it and not telling the
public the truth as well
really undermines his position as prime
minister you can't break it's not what
he did it's about the fact that he
didn't come clean i think it's both i
think it's harmful on both accounts i
think what he did shows that when people
were not seeing their loved ones who
were dying and in critical care they're
really devastated they're still grieving
about that process that they went
through and the prime minister at the
time was partying i mean that in itself
is bad enough but then to try and not
tell the public the truth and come clean
about that i think that just adds insult
to injury but many members of the public
will say he did he stood by us during um
lockdown he made sure that there was
enough money during the furlough scheme
that we could uh continue on feeding our
families and he's tried to support us as
far as energy prices are concerned let's
wait and see what happens as far as
april is concerned and on balance he is
a good prime minister we've had one of
the highest death tolls you know covid
has been very disastrous for the uk and
you know i pay tribute to those in our
nhs those scientists that helped us with
the vaccination process we haven't had
the inquiry results into what happened
we know billions of pounds were wasted
on ppe contracts and contracts that we
couldn't use and the prime minister now
is the centralization as he's lied to
the british public and he's had parties
during the lockdown i think that's a
pretty damning and serious position for
the prime minister to be in talk to me
about the role of the police
well if the law was broken the police
have an obligation to investigate that
and i think they should do that but like
i say this could be cleared up very
quickly by boris johnson yes or no did
you have a party when you shouldn't he
knows that he's the prime minister of
the country but what should the police
be doing they did uh previously i was
saying talking to alistair campbell a
few moments ago
and they did question tony blair under
caution when he was prime minister well
the police have to uphold the law you
know they have an obligation to the
british public you know we complete we
policing this country by consent if the
law was broken they have an obligation
to investigate that but like i say you
know the prime minister they can only
know
they've always been broken if they
investigate and up until now they
haven't yeah and you know i've said that
any findings that sue grey has into her
investigation should be handed over to
the police for them to look at that but
very crucial like i say i think it's not
about what the police have done it's
about boris johnson is the prime
minister of the country he set those
laws in the first place he can very
simply answer the question did you break
the law or not okay we've got a picture
that's just reaching us actually i think
this is the prime minister this morning
in his uh vehicle
there we go i can't really see him can
we but i know that that is the uh pm's
um car um he is due to be at downing
street um
shortly and then at the house of commons
by midday today for prime minister's
questions let's see if he attends i'm
sure that he will he is the prime
minister of this country of course if
for how much longer don't know um if not
him then who are you most concerned
about facing opposite the dispatch box
next time your boss gets covered well
we'll have to see what happens today i'm
not concerned about facing any of them
my job is to be the official opposition
and i'll continue to do that and hold
the government to account whoever it is
you know you know his cabinet are just
as responsible as he is and every tory
mp that props him up at the moment are
just as culpable for allowing him to
continue in his role are you confident
that he'll turn up today
he should do but you know you never know
he could have been he could get a
lateral flow test that tests positive or
not but he has the he doesn't have to
attempt parliament to tell people
whether or not he attended that party or
not he should have done that immediately
he's had many opportunities over the
last couple of days to do that he's
failed to do it and i think he should
come clean as quickly as possible good
to talk to you this morning thank you
very much indeed for taking the time to
join us thank you
always looks so cool doesn't she thanks
a lot i love your dress
thanks a lot
bear with me just a second if you would
please miss really i just want to tell
you what the newspapers are doing this
morning here we go and this is the uh
telegraph uh reporting that boris
johnson is losing support from within
his own party as the shadow of the
alleged dining street parties haunts
number 10. the eye says the pm's future
is in jeopardy as conservatives hit out
at the government
uh johnson faces potentially terminal
showdown over downing street parties is
on the front of the ft this morning
the guardian says mps are urging the
prime minister to come clean over
whether or not he attended the party
and the metro suggests the prime
minister has contempt for his victims
that's the front of the metro today